بنتاجون ربما هناك حديث عن وجود اتفاق مع
الجانب العراقي لكن في ثنايا كلام وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لويد دستن هناك اشارات
الى تلك الشروط التي يجب ان تراعى قبل
الدخول في تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق والانسحاب
انسحاب هذه القوات من الاراضي
العراقيه هل هي اشاره الى ان هذا الامر
مازال محل بحث مع الجانب
العراقي
لا بل اكثر من ذلك بيان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن خلى من اي اشاره
لمساله الانسحاب ولم يتضمن هذه الكلمه على
الاطلاق وكنا سالنا مسؤول في البنتاجون
حول غايات هذا الاجتماع واذا كان مساله
انسحاب القوات الامريكيه وقوات التحالف من
العراق موضوعه حاليا على جدول اعمال قال
بشكل واضح ان قضيه انسحاب القوات
الامريكيه ليست مثارا للبحث خلال اجتماعات
مجموعات العمل للجنه العسكريه العليا
الامريكيه العراقيه التي من المفترض ان
تنطلق خلال ايام قليله لا بل اضاف ايضا ان
التطورات الامنيه الاخيره في العراق في
اشاره الى الهجمات التي تشنها فصائل
المقاومه العراقيه على القوات الامريكيه
في العراق وايضا في سوريا والردود
الامريكيه العسكريه عليها ان هذه التطورات
لا علاقه له بانطلاق اعمال اللجنه
العسكريه العليا انما هناك التزام امريكي
وفقا الاتفاق الذي توصل اليه الحوار
الامني الثنائي المشترك الذي عقد في
السابع والثامن من اغسطس من العام الماضي
في وزاره الخارجيه بحضور مسؤولين من من
الخارجيه الامريكيه وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون ونظرائهم
العراقيين وخلال ذلك الاجتماع جرى الاتفاق
على اطلاق اللجنه الع العسكريه العليا
وزير الدفاع اعتبر ان هذه اللجنه سوف تبحث
السبيل الافضل لتطور او تحول عمل قوات
التحالف والقوات الامريكيه في العراق من
ناحيه وانها سوف تبحث عمليا بحثها
ونقاشاته سوف يكون في الاساس انطلاقا من
ثلاثه عوامل العامل الاول التهديد القائم
من تنظيم الدوله العامل الثاني الظروف
العمليات والبيئه الامنيه في العراق حاليا
والعامل الثالث هو مستوى قدرات القوات
الامن العراقيه وبالتالي هو يتحدث عن
تطوير هذه المهمه وتحويلها الى علاقه
امنيه مشتركه مستدامه اي على المدى الطويل
دون اي اشاره الى مساله وقضيه بحث انسحاب
القوات الامريكيه من العراق شكرا جزيلا لك
فادي منصور كنت معنا من البنتاجون